so i'll now move on to probabilistic
reachability for mdps okay so i'll first
give you an
introduction then i'll consider the case
of qualitative probabilistic
set reachability so this is can i reach
a
target with probability greater than
zero i'll then introduce
the optimality so equations for
probabilistic
set reachability and then i'll give you
three different
approaches for computing reachability
probabilities
so first as we saw for our dtmc's
probabilistic reachability is the
fundamental concept and quantitative
verification and it concerns the
probability of reaching some
target set so if you've got a
strategy sigma and a starting state s
then we can consider what's the
probability of
reaching set the target under the
strategy sigma when starting from the
state s
and i'll use this our notation here so
this is
similar as for
our dtmcs but we need to specify
the strategy first to resolve the
non-determinism
so if we consider a mdp well we've got a
set of
possible strategies so we can do the
best or
worst case slide analysis so this is the
lower or
the upper bounds based over all
strategies so we can either consider so
the minimum
probability of reaching the target
starting from state s so here we take
that infimum
over all strategies so this is
the minimum it's like probability or we
can take the
supreme overall strategies and this
gives us the maximum probability
of reaching the target over all
strategies
so what i'll also use sometimes as for
select dtmcs is like the vector of
slight probabilities so either the
vector the vector of minimum
reachability probabilities or the vector
of maximum reachability probabilities
so let's first look at two examples
so first let's first look at this simple
our dtmc we saw earlier and let's
consider the probability
that we reach the target set tails so
if we consider our
strategy from except before sigma i the
first select select selects b for the
first i it's
like minus one times and instead s one
and
then select c so um
it's like sigma one select c so the
first time that it's in
sms one so we go from s0 to s1
and then with probability one half we
end up in
s3 on the other hand if we consider
strategy that first chooses b
um the first time in s1 and then always
chooses
c well we can see so after that there's
always probability
point half that it either goes to s2 or
s3
so set the probability
of moving to out of
the target set tails being so reached is
so again
0.5 now if we consider the minimum step
probability
well we've got the strategy that always
chooses b in state
s s one and in this case
we'll either always take this loop here
or we'll move back to s1
sorry back to s0 then move to s1 then
we'll choose
b again and we'll go back to s0 and then
back to s1
so the minimum probability for this um
mdp is it's like zero while
uh it's like the maximum is point half
and there's
a number of different strategies that
slightly achieve this as we've seen both
sigma one and
sigma 2 so achieve this and in fact
sigma n for any n
will also give slight probability 0.5
now let's consider a slightly modified
mdp
where if if we choose action b there's
still a slight probability of 0.7 of
going to s
0 but now instead of the self loop
we now move to state s 3 or our our
target with
probability of 0.3 now if we consider
sigma one in this case so we go to
s slope one and then there's a um point
five star probability
it's like reaching s three
on the other hand for uh sigma 2
if we first choose um b then we've got a
slight probability point point point
um 0.3
or we go back to s just like zero then
the second time we we take this um
transition c and we've got or this
action c and we've got a 50 50 chart so
it's
0.3 plus 0.7 times 0.5
for sigma three well so we either
um have the point three or we go back
and then it's like the second time we
again choose b
so we then have point seven times
point three or we go back to
s0 and then it's like the third time we
choose c so we have 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.5 in it's like the third case
so here so the max at the minimum
is still 0.5 and that correspond sorry
now except the minimum is 0.5
as opposed to a point as opposed to zero
and here we just choose c
so the first time and so the maximum is
0.1
and here so we always this time if we
always choose b
then eventually we will always take this
loop here and we will end up in s slot
three
because so the probability of always
taking this branch will be it's like
zero
okay so that's an example now for
it it turns out that um for
reachability so probabilities we can
just consider
memory less strategies so these are
strategies that always pick the same
choice or same as an action in a
our state so these are also known as
suppositional markov or
a markovian or simple strategies
and here we can just um write them as
apes
select mapping to available actions
and then the induced or dtmc
can have the same state space as the
original
mdp so just to give you one
example so from the previous example
if we consider the strategy select sigma
one that picks
c in state s one then the induced
our dtmc has the same state space
as the mvp and in state s1 we just have
the transitions corresponding to
the action c so we go to s2 with
probability 0.5
and we go to s3 with probability 0.5
so there are other classes of our
strategies we've got finite
memory select strategy so here there's a
finite
number of modes which can govern the
choices that the strategy
slide makes and they can formally be
defined by deterministic finance
automaton
and um the induced finite um the induced
or dtmc is um now
can be a finite mdp so
so recall in such a general case the
induced
um dtmc is
it's like infinite state because the set
of um
states corresponds to the set of all
finite paths
um corresponding to the adversary
in the mdp we also have
randomized slight strategies so here it
maps a
finite path to a probability or
distribution over
the available slot actions
and these generalize the deterministic
ones that i've
introduced so far and these will still
induce a possibly infinite state
of dtmc and we also have the class of
fair
our strategies which um
impose fairness so assumptions for
example
if an action is available so infinitely
so often then so eventually that action
will be
it's like chosen so
um now i will go on to
probabilistic reachability for mdps and
i'll first consider
select the qualitative case um of
um where the minimum or except max
finding the set of states for which
either the minimum or maximum
reachability so probability
is greater than zero
okay so let's first consider so we've
got
so here so we want either side the
minimum slot probability from state s
up so reaching the target t
is greater than zero or the maximum
probability of when starting from state
s
so we reached the target t is greater
than
zero so for
the max case so this is the set of
states for which
the maximum probability is greater than
zero so this just corresponds to
non probabilistic
select reachability so we start from our
uh our targets set
and and while it and while we find new
our states
then we update our set of our states
so we find all sites let's states
for which there is some some action and
some
and some state in our in
the reachability set we found so far
so that we can enter that it's like [ __ ]
state and we keep
doing this until our set
does not start change this is just
a standard of reachability we start from
by the target
then we add in all states that can reach
the target in once one step then all
this all all the states that can reach
outside the target in two and
so we keep going until our set of states
does not change
okay so in
or the min case is very
similar but we are required under
all possible non-deterministic
choices there is a a transition
into our current target set
so that's all that select changes there
so let's now move on to the
optimality slight equations for
select probabilistic it's like
reachability so
the values of um certainly minimum
probabilities
can be um are the unique solutions of
the following sets of
slight equations so it's like the
problem
the minimum probability for state s
so if it's in it's like the target
obviously it
it's one if there's
if um if if
p min is not it's like greater than
or zero therefore it's so equal to
zero therefore we set it equal to zero
and so otherwise it's um
it's like defined select recursively
based on
the successor states so it's the minimum
set probability so it's like the minimum
over
available actions and this is just
like the probability that we move to
state s prime if we choose
action a in state s and then the minimum
sub probability
from state s prime of getting to the
our target so this is what is known as
an instance of
the bellman side equation
and it's it's like the basis of um
dynamic programming techniques for mdps
so for max it's almost the same
all that we change is here so the second
case is the
case where the maximum slight
probability is equal to
so zero as it's like opposed to so so
the minimum
and here we take the max over the it's
like available
actions well it's like previously we
took the minimum over the
available actions
so as i said
so previously set memory less such
strategies are actually
sufficient for probabilistic it's like
reachability
and they are strategies that always pick
the same
choice in a state and it
so just to be more it's like precise
what i mean by it's less sufficient
are that there do exist memoryless
strategies that achieve both so the
minimum probabilistic
set reachability it's like values and
the maximum probabilistic
reachability it's like select values
and they can easily be are constructed
from the optimal
optimality equations so you can just
after you've got
other values you can just find in each
slight
state which is like the action that
actually
yields that that yields
the minimum of value
so just to add at this point that
memoryless strategies are not always
it's less sufficient for example
although they are
sufficient for reachability in turn
in turn-based games we actually need
finite memory
strategies when we consider bandit
select properties
so here why do we need it here well
for example um
if we have a if so we want to reach a
set of states it's like within a certain
number of slight steps then if we've got
a
large number of sites like steps left
then
it it might be best to choose a
longer route that has a higher our
probability but if we've only got a few
steps left then it might be better to
choose a
it's like a shorter route that has a
lower
a probability it's also needed for both
ltl and
automata based slot properties
we also need randomized strategies for
our concurrent games and for so
reachability
like properties they can be select
memoryless but we need them to be
it's like randomized on the other hand
we need um both
finite except memory
strategies and randomized strategies
for multi objective select properties
okay so let's finally get on to site
computing reachability
set probabilities that i will cover in
the final
select video